ich bin nackt und das kann nur eine
sache bedeutung wir hatten heute den
amazon beauty wellness kalender aus
natürlich nicht müsste langsam echt
meine locker und figur da war ich so
sportlich unterwegs und musste nicht
mein bauch ein ziel ich weiß ich bin
trotzdem noch wunderschön und schlank
und super und
trotzdem packe ich jetzt mal die hupe
nein aber zum adventskalender haben für
mich eine ganz tiefe bedeutung denn der
amazon vans kalender in 2016 oder 17 war
der erste adventskalender den ich
überhaupt ausgepackt habe es ist zwar
nicht der normale amazon adventskalender
sondern die beauty version heute aber
ich glaube den normalen verkaufen sie
gar nicht mehr sie mich gerade vom
gesicht her erkannt ich bin zwar messer
ich weiß bin ungeschminkt so wie gott
mich erschaffen hat das ändert sich
jetzt hoffentlich ich weiß nicht was für
produkte drin sind und ich habe euch
gehört ich werde versuchen alles
nachzurechnen und schauen aber wirklich
seine 79 99 wert ist
das ist wie dieses foto geschenkt wo
dann eine seite alles aufklappt
einziehen
die haben wir das wunderbare stück ist
von der größe sehr angenehm
ich finde das design sehr sehr schön
kann man sich super irgendwo hinstellen
wenn man eine lange große kommode habe
natürlich ist wirklich sehr sehr lang
und diesen kalender kann man auch wieder
gefüllt dafür vor ich noch einmal amazon
sage oder wie toll dieser
adventskalender ist dieses video ist
nicht gesponsert und jetzt alle dieses
videos nicht gesponsert das ist meine
meinung ich packe einfach nur einen
adventskalender aus und sagt was ich
dazu so für gedanken habe wir fangen an
mit türchen nummer eins in kirchen
nummer eins befindet sich gabor kenne
barcoo von diesen glasfläschchen die
waren schon mal im adventskalender drin
da klappt man so den deckel ab und dann
schnitt man sich das serum genauso ins
gesicht
[Musik]
aber das soll jetzt hier eine creme sein
der weg die pflegecreme für jugendliche
staffel wirken der haut und einen
strahlenden teint feiner linien und
fältchen trockenheit und kleine
unregelmäßigkeiten würden reduziert sie
sind es mich aber sie würden würde ich
wie die creme von der mama road trip an
den augen muss man so ein tippen mit dem
publikum blieb liebte also ich habe
jetzt einen schönen glanz auf der haut
aber mit liegt heute in creme und jetzt
schauen wir einfach mal wie viel die
kostet
29 euro für diesen bisschen gram
dem türchen nummer 2 befindet sich
nagellack ist super guck mal weg ein
nagellack drauf hat das ist so dieses
richtige christmas rot das kann man
immer tragen also die hat sich wunderbar
auftragen lassen und das ist einmal und
es reicht vollkommen es ist super
gleichmäßig und sieht einfach sehr sehr
gut aus ein wunder dass die so gut ist
das kostet hier auch zehn euro super
nagellack superklasse
geht's mit tüchern nummer drei wie auch
immer diesen adventskalender auf
instagram von wir gewinnen wird hier
sind oder nagellack fleck das ist hier
dass ich das verschickt oder das
skandinavische
bunning denn wartet in stalker neuen
tänzen
kriemhild rosenduft und 5 prozent
schützende cream verbinden sich in
dieser pflegenden formel die alle
hauttypen mit lang anhaltender
feuchtigkeit versorgt von schwarzkopf &
henkel
natürlich ihr skandinavischer beruf sehr
angenehm riecht sehr sauber aber ich
werde sie nicht ausprobieren ich werde
sie verlosen denn wenn ich alles kann
ausgepackt hat befindet ihr selber neu
und dann habt ihr die chance auf
instagram sondern krebs zu gewinnen in
einem selbst gepackten adventskalender
das ist ja das ist ein normaler preis
der uns mal ausnahmsweise nicht
schockiert 75 milliliter 75 milliliter
92 runde auf drei euro für die handcreme
endlich mal einen preis den man auch
nachvollziehen kann und hier hilfe
befindet sich dann auch mal türchen
nummer fünf
ja da bin ich fan da bin ich fan leute
gerade kristalle vom kneipp und
verwöhnen die
screening und dann macht man sich einen
schönen tag in der badewanne hat auch
noch eine schöne stunden bis in nietheim
also auch nie warum habt ihr es auch bei
kneipp habe ich so das gefühl ich
vertraue dieser marke so komplett weil
sie so medizinisch glaube ich aus die
dort kostete gerade
kristalle bade kristalle euro cremo
piening anrufen von 30 ist packe ich
euch natürlich in die verlosung rein das
jetzt gefällt mir dieser adventskalender
ganz gut jetzt aber nikolaus dran und
sind wichtiger moment für den
adventskalender muss ich sagen
ich habe vergessen türchen nummer 4 auf
zu machen weil ich den preis von dem
geguckt habe wir hatten gerade natürlich
immer führen wir machen jetzt mal ganz
kurz natürlich nummer 4 auf klar was
haben wir denn hier war ein prima an
dieser marke diese marke habe ich jetzt
auch immer nur männer sind wenns
kalender videos gesehen 3
[Musik]
der ist sogar getötet
also man sieht auf jeden fall dass es
auch für meine augen bisschen helles
aber ich dachte gerade das ist ja ganz
praktisch ist bei lidschatten wenn man
jetzt knallige farben nimmt wenn auch
bei dunkler haut der primer ein bisschen
heller ist weil ich habe zum beispiel
von oskar sohn weißen primer bekommen
und dann knallen die farben so richtig
krass drauf also das ist eine weiße
leinwand dann denn die dunklere haut
habt benutzt die helleren primer
schreibt gerne was dazu den kommentaren
ich kenne nicht tatsächlich zu wenig aus
so und jetzt kommt was kriegen wie
geschenkbuch sieht schon mal besonders
aus
der vor
ich hab dir natürlich schon in zwei
varianten also dem und einmal das große
teil luna play man muss sagen sie doch
besonders häufig gerade ein eis die ja
wenn es genau auspacke also der reinigt
anscheinend durch diesen orden ganz doll
lieb ohren das einzige was ich an diesen
dingen nicht so gut finde ist dass er
ungefähr 400 plus anwendungen ist und
dann kann man ihn nicht mehr nach laden
das heißt danach und das ding in den
müll aber natürlich nicht in den
hausmüll sondern dann in den
wertstoffhof elektromüll wo es dann ja
auch recycle wird aber trotzdem habe ich
euch in die verlosung rein dann könnt
ihr es vielleicht zu hause ausprobieren
kann jetzt einfach mal zehn euro in die
kasse weil es anscheinend dieses ding
nicht so gibt also nicht unschlagbar
ganz schön großes paket für so ein
kleines ding wohnkomplex augen creme mit
q10
folgende friedhof peptide peptide wirkt
der faltenbildung entgegen
dermatologischen augen ärztlich geprüfte
sebamed an
[Musik]
gut bewertet 1400 bewertungen sieben
euro uns interessiert nicht mal habt ihr
damit erfahrung benutzt wenn ja schreibt
gerne was ihr dazu sagt ich habe mir mal
ganz bisschen auf die hand gemacht war
nach diesem weg mein gesicht einfach so
eingecremt sein da die fühlt sich auf
jeden fall schon mal gut angelegt auch
so wie sie aussieht einfach so kannst du
vertrauen ich mache deine zweiten blick
ist einfach unglaublich frau
vanessa 18 jahre jünger geworden
ich hab mich nur eingeklebt doch mal
8 1 kalender macht natürlich spaß ich
ihn vergessen was für krasse produkt
einfach drin sind so wie zum beispiel
ich dachte gerade das ist ein probe
shampoo das ist eine hand desinfektion
herr und pro tag acht stunden
feuchtigkeit
ist dass wir eine hantel selektion jeder
produziert ist gerade seit diesem
typischen darf geruch wenig alkohol also
es reicht jetzt nicht so brennend am
28 stunden feuchtigkeit sollte man aber
nicht ständig seine hände ganz gründlich
waschen dann kann das doch nicht sein
das ist die ganze zeit acht stunden
feuchtigkeit drauf fällt
meine lieblingszahl dean immer noch
glaube dass kalender videos werdet ihr
niemals wieder vergessen dass neun meine
lieblingszahl ist die nummer 9 befindet
sich eine scharfe pro-ge wenn die nerven
tschechien wollten sie uns erstaunt dass
man sagt das ist alles drin jetzt kommt
es hier es ist aber ein produkt was
einfach wieder partys für trockene und
empfindliche kopfhaut im winter im
dezember ist die kopfhaut trockner und
kostet jetzt hier so ein shampoo würde
sich cent jährlich weiß wir sind
enttäuschend ja sage ich ganz ehrlich
dafür wird aber türchen nummer 10 unsere
besser
wilders-gegner
marina intensive soforthilfe für
trockene und spröde lippen buttersäure
40 machen wir mal nicht zu empfehlen
lanolin teil vom schaf bugs enthalten
gefällt mir gar nicht nicht zu empfehlen
ich hatte durch dieses mittel sehr
schnell entzündete lippen und habe
dieses balsam anschließend sofort
entsorgt ich kann euch das nicht in die
verlosung box packung wenn das
anscheinend auch reaktionen hervorruft
das würde ich nicht aushalten wenn mir
jemand schreibt der linken er wird sich
wieder in der welt könne gepackt keine
liebe mehr alle bei mir sind nicht so
flüssig habe aber auch sehr trocken weiß
nicht ob man sehen kann aber ich habe
wirklich seit es kälter wird einfach
wieder so eine übrigens trockene lippen
findet der geruch geht voll klaus
richter nach naturkosmetik flüssig war
es jetzt auch nicht wenn zwar gut tiefen
festes shampoo fettiges haar befreit von
überschüssen teilt mit reis milch ich
finde sehr toll dass marken einem die
möglichkeit geben quasi wären
nachhaltigere produkte zu kaufen klar
verkauften die wer nebenbei immer noch
ganz viele plastik shampoo flaschen aber
wenn jetzt alle aber darauf umsteigen
würden und sowas kaufen würden dann
würde nie wäre ja automatisch ja davon
produzieren weniger von plastikflaschen
es lief sehr gut und dieses stück seite
könnte für 53 gehören
die haare werden sauber ja das war's
dann aber auch schon
kirchen
warum ist alle türchen darum
den adressaten auch wieder seine marke
die meine mutter benutzt die 17 mal aus
wie eine probe ich glaube es muss der
probe sein dass ludger und das ist
irgendwie so ein produkt selbst ein
produkt
43 also das ist hier wirklich alle waren
350 das ist hier wieder mal eine probe
ich bin mir nicht so sicher was es aber
überhaupt ist am besten wird die essent
wenn sie nach dem reinigen und vor der
anwendung ihres lieblings serums oder
den aufgetragen worden dem auftragen
leicht schütteln und die formel dann
mittels der mitte das gesicht nach außen
in die haut
ja also ist so eine flüssige konsistenz
hier soll irgendetwas anderem eine sich
also nach dem video habe ich auf jeden
fall einen gesunden glanz in der fresse
fühlt sich ganz gut an wie die anderen
sehen aber ich verstehe nicht was es ist
wir sind mit der hälfte durch das ist so
viel ich bin damals 13 die ich liebe die
die weil es ja schon drin und ich finde
sie wirklich richtig gut weil selbst so
ein sehr
einschläfernden beruhigen dürfte man
sich vorm schlafengehen ein und dann ist
man in diesem duft drin und dann freut
man sich und sehr schön sehr sehr
beruhigend amt in die verlosung durch
ende machte eine ganz große verpackung
für
[Musik]
gucken wir drauf bleibt aber der lässt
sich so schön auftragen getrocknet
vielleicht ein bisschen schneller mit
einer kreis für den eyeliner 13 euro
dass man wieder ihren stabiler preise
macht 15
obwohl das habe ich noch nie benutzt ich
habe aber auch dann wenn es länder war
da dieses ding um die frisierten haare
glatt zu machen also ich hab ich ein
paar produkte die ich letztes jahr am
adventskalender hatte die ich echt immer
noch sehr gerne benutzt man nimmt sich
was von dem bruder was sieht babypuder
sondern macht man sich das in die hände
und dann verrät man das macht doch
keinen sinn da macht man es in die haare
es fühlt sich aber eher an wieso
ich bin ja schon dick im haar gesegnet
deswegen sehe ich jetzt nicht so die
notwendigkeiten volumen reinzumachen
aber wenn ich mir vorstelle dass ich so
feines dünnes haar hab was kostest durak
euro 50 nummer 16 ist das etwa die
eigenmarke von amazon feind ob die sich
durchsetzen kann oder eine schwarze
gesichtsmaske süße verpackung mit diesem
ding hier aber ja euro wird verlor sich
natürlich an euch weil ich euch so liebt
was haben wir denn hier in der ecke was
versteckt sich hier ist das etwa die nur
17 flaschen immer kleiner rucola die
marine creme anti aging es mir schon
wieder dass es das motto ring 22 euro
will die
linke krimi ist verschlossen deswegen
werden sie jetzt nicht aufmachen extra
und natürlich sie an euch verlost da
haben wir auch schon türchen nummer acht
was schweres
meine nichte kommen mich besuchen und
sie hat manchmal verklärtes habe das
behalte ich jetzt für sie instant die
tagging conditioner
aufsprühen und haare aus käme falls man
sie ein bisschen verknotet euro 40 in
der 19 ich denke oh la la long lasting
bin ich mir nicht sicher ob ich ihn
ausprobieren eigentlich will ich den
ausprobieren doch die farbe finde ich
aber sehr schön die ist so ein bäriger
rom
[Musik]
für mich ein bisschen als ob ich mich
mit der schminke von meiner mama
geschminkt war ich nur ein kleiner und
der lippenstift drauf also sollte
make-up locken nicht aussehen hat ist
das ist eine stabile farbe ein bisschen
rötlicher hätte ich mir aber gewünscht
gerade um es passend zu machen mit dem
roten nagellack wäre ein guter ton
natürlich noch ein ganz bisschen besser
gewesen aber mir gefällt die qualität
sehen euro für das gute ding
hier nochmal 20
wieder diese komische zahnpasta das ist
ja gibts die zahnpasta mit anis salou
sich 125 milliliter und 85 kosten acht
euro das heißt ungefähr ein drittel
nehmen wir davon 250
zweimal das
350 wissen wir schon mal lustig dass die
einfach das gleiche nochmal rein gemacht
haben ich frage mich ob das absicht ist
oder ob das irgendwie in der produktion
was schief gelaufen ist oder was da in
der schweiz 22 hoffentlich ist da nicht
wieder nivea seife drin nicht das aber
wieder ähnlich eine zweite handcreme von
drei euro für die nummer 23 das
vorletzte türchen morgens heiligabend
ich mache dieses riesen türchen auf und
findet neutrogena
revitalisierende tagespflege neutrogena
ist ja eigentlich ja früher habe ich das
immer so als diese teure gesichtspflege
makel gesehen das ist einfach eine
stabile sich scream denke ich acht euro
das ich habe ich sie mir früher nicht
leisten können die mache ich natürlich
jetzt nicht ja und werde sie in die
verlosung mit reinpacken so jetzt kommt
aber leute habe ich letztes jahr
also ich kann jetzt gerade eigentlich
nur besser werden wir haben hier das 24
türchen ja es ist wieder sehr schwer
ja das ist ja cool ein fön eines ist
eine gute sache man kann ja immer so
eine reise von super gebrauchen ich
dachte gerade als ich das in der packung
gesehen habe schon wieder ein haar
produkt als letztes türchen weil ich
gesagt letztes jahr gab es nämlich einen
kleinen ein ganz kleines glätteisen wir
doch ein bisschen größer als gedacht das
war scheiße building jetzt nicht
auspacken weil ich den verlosen werde
ich hab nämlich gefühlt aber das ist
jetzt doch wenn ich das so sehe ist das
ein praktischer das ist echt fettes
türchen dass man jetzt auch nicht
vergessen ich in meiner ansprüche leute
ihr könnt euch auch schon wieder
entspannen und regt euch meinen
kommentar ich auf meine ansprüche was
adventskalender angehen extrem weil es
ist so krass eine creme kostet 50 euro
und das ding kostet 13 euro
34 diese creme kostet mehr als dieser
verletzt ist aber die wichtige frage
gefällt mir der kalender wenn es um das
design geht gefällt wie der kalender 100
die frage ist jetzt ob mir die produkte
gefallen also mein absolutes highlight
muss ich nur sagen ich
habe ihn für 74 eur 95 74 eur 95 gut der
ist jetzt aber wieder
zum wiederverkauf 440 euro für das
doppelte ich hab den 474 euro gekauft
wenn man beim adventskalender guckt
sieht man auch die ganzen produkte okay
da jetzt zusammengerechnet ich bin aber
ein wert von 165 euro gekommen was hat
einen amazon über den kalender gesagt
kann da leute hinter den 24 türchen
verbirgt sich ein inhalt um die
300 euro
165 sind nicht
300 euro skandal klein scheiße also ich
würde sagen dieser kalender hat einen
wahren wert um 165 euro man bekommt ihn
für 74 eur bzw jetzt nicht mehr und
lohnt sich das natürlich natürlich wie
man sich dieser adventskalender man
kriegt für 100 euro mehr sachen aber die
frage ist wieder braucht man diese
produkte wirklich zum beispiel weil man
handcreme ja oder so ein serum noten
entfesselung spray ich sag mal so wenn
man gerne sachen ausprobiert und
experimentiert und neue produkte
kennenlernen möchte dann ist es perfekt
kann man eh schon sein repertoire hat an
standardprodukten die man gerne benutzt
und machen den man vertraut dann macht
dieser adventskalender überhaupt keinen
sinn weil es dann einfach nur es ist
dann einfach zeug in deinem haus das ist
mein fazit für diesen adventskalender
werde viele produkte aus diesem anlass
kalender neu verpacken also zum beispiel
dann diesen adventskalender wieder
füllen und verlosen dafür müsst ihr mir
verfolgen da gibt es dann regelmäßig
rennkalender verlosungen und ich wünsche
euch sehr viel spaß und seid ihr glück
dabei kommt da ein mal rüber und gerne
abonnieren ihr könnt aber auch gerne
hier mein aktuell man einen kanal
abonnieren ich muss was elf nicht ob es
zu sorgen wie kann ich mich so schwer
konzentrieren gerade also was sie machen
auch instagram gehen genau und da
erfolgen und dann bei den gewinnspielen
mitmachen und hier auch abonieren das
wäre ganz fantastisch wir sehen uns beim
nächsten mal wieder ich hoffe euch hat
viel spaß gemacht und ich hoffe ihr seid
genießt dass ich die preise
aufgeschrieben haben was also muss ich
bei den anderen weiteren auch versuchen
obwohl ich sagen muss jetzt kommen ein
paar adventskalender da ist das ein
bisschen schwierig mit demnach zählen
aber wir werden sehen zu machen können